We covered a lot of ground in this lesson spanning DHTs, CDNs, key
based routing and how to avoid overloading the matter data server
and the origin server using the concept of sloppy DHT. What Coral
System does is offer a vehicle to democratize content
generation, storage, and distribution, through a participatory approach.
I encourage you to read the paper in full, to understand how the system has
been implemented. Of course, Commerical CDNs such
as Acmite, do not operate in this way.
They're in it for the money. They
contractually mirror the content for a customer. And
they deploy their own additional mirrors to
deal with dynamic increase in volume of requests.
With this discussion, we complete the lesson module on Internet Scale Computing.